my whole life changed with five simple
words delivered casually by a relative
at a party you know you're autistic
right initially I rejected the idea I
was 30 and my knowledge of autism was
based on TV caricatures I thought
autistic people were math Wizards who
lacked empathy and loved
trains of course there's no one way to
be autistic I'm a loudmouth creative
with an overactive empathy chip who can
barely add two digits together contrary
to stereotypes autistic people can be
creative emotional and highly empathetic
kind while saying exactly what we mean
my diagnosis gave me a framework to
explain my experience to loved ones and
the wider World some people see autism
as an illness whilst others call it a
superpower to me it's neither it's
simply the blueprint for who I am and to
cure me of my autism would be to cure me
of myself